hello welcome to random CER the live
streaming show every Thursday at 11 a.m.
Pacific which would now mean 6:00 p.m.
in the UK and Ireland today we are
playing probably archery it's most
likely archery but I'll be honest I
don't really know cuz I've intentionally
not played it because I've heard that
much like Surgeon Simulator this one is
a little bit weird with the controls
scheme uh there's also a bunch of stuff
going on in this menu uh target practice
don't
miss the Berserker ah why are all these
naked men running past the screen The
Noose
zerog so many
random game modes and over here zombie
soccer sitting here on multiplayer it's
pretty fleshed Out video game Southeast
games made this available on Steam for
10 bucks it's actually in a uh in a
Indie Gala pack at the moment as well
but um let's just hop right into
it okay oh oh
Jesus this is familiar
whoa there we can let's try that again
bam there you go imagine how hard this
game would be if it kept throwing up
Windows prompts every two seconds all
right here we go so I'm moving this with
my
left my with the with the mouse I feel
like this is not the way a wrist should
work I feel like maybe it's
whoa what okay he's got an
arrow put the arrow in the
thing and
then and then let drop the arrow perfect
I got an achievement I'm winning at this
video game
already
okay so left Mouse button is grab and
release to knock the arrow it's the
right Mouse button but how do I move
okay let's do this again and then knock
and put it close and then knock hand too
far from string all right the
string
I got this Mom there you go there you
go okay so if I hold the shift button I
move the right
arm oh this is going to be easy
okay there and now back to
you
and no all right I can do it I can do
what the [__] oh man if you hold Q it
moves his shoulder and if you hold e it
moves moves his elbow this is so
specific okay also I believe the string
is currently going through my arm which
is kind of terrifying okay see the
problem is here I don't know how to do
real
archery knock the arrow how is that too
far it's
it's Jesus
Christ
okay this epic music is in stark
contrast to my ability to do this simple
task yeah there's the elbow it's pumping
it up baby
yeah this should be probably
weightlifting I'd be way better shoulder
over here over
here and then I'm going to use you
there and then bring it back with the
E yes I'm the best archer in the world
oh Jesus Christ it's taking me like two
minutes to get the thing in the thing
okay uh uh uh uh uh can I just run up
and stab the targets instead okay shift
shift to move the left the right
arm okay here we go which one should I
hit I'm going to go for the closest one
this one right
here just to make the point that there
is no aiming reticle here
whatsoever all
right and I also have no idea how
archery
works
cuz I didn't grow up in [__] Middle
Earth all
right here we
go I'm already conscious of the
anticlimax that is about to happen when
I release this Arrow okay here we
go watch okay what do I have to do I
have to release I'm so terrified to take
my finger off any of the buttons right
now ah [__] [__] okay we're okay whoa
what's going on there no that's not
right come back this way
no
no I just do this just compensate with
my left arm that's perfect
no
okay okay I need to move this arm over
again
knock okay that's not straight enough
need to be dead straight
bam
nope no it's getting worse there there
you go that's slightly better maybe bit
higher move up the
L is this what the like archery game
that archery enthusiasts have been
waiting for for like 20 years oh here we
go
okay all right there there there I'm
guessing what I have to do is release
the left button so here we go oh I hit
it oh my
God oh my God I really didn't think I
was going to hit
it
what
what I'm doing this is I'm doing my
Degeneration
X this is my impression of
XO all
right okay left arm left hand here go
that way right hand go that way okay I
think I'm getting used to this give me
an arrow give me another arrow pull it
out from my
spine you go I'm going to try and hit
the furthest one the one over there and
then we'll get into some actual game
modes once I pump up my arm a bit more
yeah all
right am I swaying in the wind as well
all right here we go there and then I
need to move the it's the wrist is the
problem for the
accuracy Okay this may be a case of me
biting off more than I can shoot
yeah elbow
back arm down wrist that way uh no oh
you have to be get it closer to the wire
a little bit higher a little bit
higher oh I'm So Pro at this okay here
we go
bit a bit bit of Dutch on it there I'm
going to hit it
like hit a Robin Hood King of Thieves
style do like this is like some South
Central LA archery where they're just
like shoot yeah come on
man real gangsters hold their bows
sideways all
right oh I missed it oh well you know
what
I think that's enough I think I'm Pro
enough at archery to play this video
game against Real apples don't miss why
is that man got a popcorn for his
head the fool and here I thought I was
the
fool the target wait the Apple's on top
of his head
okay was that a oh Dutch courage he's
got he's he's gotten drunk of what I can
only assume
cider
okay right is that a know this about
archery culture apparently what you do
is you get your hunky male model friend
who has an Apple for a head to put an
apple on top of his head after he's
gotten rip [__] on
cider here we
go guess this is how they got their E10
plus no
no no all right
okay here we
go
perfect now
you then back that way yeah was my hand
always that
close I'm starting to sound like a
Stoner Man where's my hand my hands can
touch everything but themselves oh
wait all
right you go away you're too you're too
near or
far uh uh it's the only action I can do
with any sort of
consistency there you go pull it
yeah wrist wrist wrist okay then knock
Arrow bend
elbow bend the elbow more is this elbow
broken what's okay
there
yes okay if I was this apple man I would
not be too jazzed about what's happening
here God that apple is so small I'm not
even sure if I can hit the green one let
alone the one on his
head okay I'm
sorry I'll tell your wife you love
her let's try that
again
no
there
no this must be excruciating for
him oh it definitely murdered him I'm
sorry applean man restart level I can do
this why am I a bag of wheat with a with
a thing can I change my dude
change my dude name d no and rs face
obviously Arrow Trail
green got Fishbowl we got the Giant Bomb
logo
okay what CBS make this
game all right let's do that then what
else we got robot
arms I can't choose the race of my robot
this game is so
racist real arms
robot arms okay this Oculus Rift support
oh man this game is genuinely great all
right start level back to game My Robot
arms hopefully this should make it
easier cuz that'll be more
efficient straight
arm I think your archery arm should be
straight your and then your your your
your other arm your your arrow arm
should be Loosey Goosey
and then bend the
wrist Jesus Christ this is infuriating
whoa robot pull-ups
yep there no uh
there
yes okay but more
here this is the hardest part is trying
to get it to actually
knock oh
no I love how he even attempts
those here we go here we go here we go
so that
way [__] then you have to you're you go
over here
more straighten up no straighten
up oh how long do we have to play this
game this is this is the first game mode
I'm already losing my goddamn mind uh go
there turn that
no is that even straight I can't even
tell and then you you go
here you go bend that way nailed
it I don't think all right
there oh this is the worst how I God
really this could just go anywhere if I
try and lift it up and then straighten
it that way is that the best way to do
it maybe I feel like if you were to hold
a bow that way with your wrist you'd
probably shatter your wrist but you know
what I think I got
this forgot to pull back the
arrow oh give me another
one
Arrow
back and release o okay all I have to do
then is keep is keep going
down is keep like
which button do I let go this one all I
have to do is
keep like just changing the angle down a
bit more how about
that and oh for God's sake
this ah all
right all right next one I want to see
what the Berserker is oh Jesus Christ
he's running right towards me oh my God
uh give me an arrow
uh no no pick up another arrow that's
the worst
there [__]
I'm what did he die too I don't even
know what happened all right I can do
this so I have to get it up there quick
straight elbow give me an
arrow knock it there there
no get in the [__]
thing all right all right all right I
got
this okay so it's move that
there like okay there right get an
arrow put it in
quick bend your [__] do it there oh I
forgot to bend the thing back all right
four times a
charm okay you go there you go there
turn turn
arrow get in get
in get in yes oh
[__] okay all right we're getting there
you can see progress with every time I
do this I'm slightly less
awful all right
here
okay and and yes die
[__] yes another one
oh no that way God this is so intense
you know get in it was in a second ago
there oh he's so much closer this time
all right get in get in oh why are they
still alive then in the bottom this is
terrifying oh oh good I got a bit
distance this time he's got something
else in his hand
though I'm no fool I'm waiting till he
gets nice up and close he's got a shield
oh this is
[__] yes oh
no no there's two of them uh oh [__] I'm
not even GNA get one of them here all
right okay I have to take the plunge on
one of you
guys oh well I'm
[__]
okay okay is there another like is there
other somebody in the chat said there's
other
characters oh with these ones oh there
different things do different things all
right I'm going to be fishball head man
then
with nice black
arms Advanced targets War band
exter I don't even know what to do next
okay I'm going to keep going in this way
Advanced
targets oh Jesus
Christ okay let's try this out moving
Target maybe if I do the moving Target
section I'll be better at the screaming
Berserker
man give me an
arrow uh no no this arm other arm Bend
it that way yeah and then put it in the
thing straighten your wrist young
man no it's the hardest part by miles is
trying to get this bastardy Arrow into
the
no Bend there perfect need to straighten
that
arm every every time I hear myself
explain it then I can't do it the next
time like that maybe nailed it all
right moving Target go NOP all
right I need to practice if I'm to get
more than five in Berserker or four I
probably got
four no
yeah and then you go over there and then
you come back over
here right then you straighten up stop
being such a piece of [__] and then come
on all
right and
you yes
okay h
a oh God damn it okay look at that one
in the background that's Flo floating
away like a bird that's ridiculous
that's some Pro probably archery game
happening there all
right
a oh come
on if I'm
to if I'm to live my lifelong dream of
being Morgan Freeman in that Robin Hood
movie I need
to
oh I'll never be a sarson's son come
on G oh GE I'm getting worse I'm losing
my
patience somebody in the chat says
something hilarious but I can't repeat
it but I just want them to know that is
brilliant have I what is going on here I
I've only just realized I'm using this
using this
bow like some sort of idiot look at
apparently you can do I didn't know you
could do this
okay
oh next time Mom I'll do it this time I
swear just get the thing in
the straighten
up e is it e is it wrist it's wrist I
need to straighten my
wrist and then and and then do it that
way and then oscillate pivot
pivot and then
you and then nailed it
no this is getting super ghetto I cannot
I'm
like it's like sideways oh jeez just
like sideways shooting now like drive by
shooting style come
on
yeah oh come
on it's
always I saw you knock a second ago come
on I'm going to try and hit the flag the
flag looks way easier look at that just
sitting
there
ah oh come on I want to see a third
person shot at this guy he's just
surrounded by all the arrows he's
dropped all right look at this his hand
just like broken
like can I kill myself is that an option
can I just turn this on
myself
I just want to hit it once just once
video
game all
right here we go this is it
folks I swear to
God I think statistically it's actually
impressive that I've managed to miss
this many times
shoot it through my own
arm bam no okay that was never going to
work this epic music is not
helping
a I need to aim
higher that's what some of you in the
chat are saying and the rest of you
saying lower
all right yeah yeah nailed it got
it this wrist needs to straighten up I
know that for
sure and this needs to go
there said every time you knock you have
to basically just reset it
again nice and
straight move over
there hit that moving one here we go
no
C this is like oh
god oh Jesus just put the arrow in the
thing
there I think this is a battle of
patience more than anything else mine
and
yours
all right so it's here but it's
higher here we
go here but higher but more
accurate
yes look that's it now it's bro the ice
has been broken I can get a second one
immediately now watch watch how Pro I am
oh [__] this all right I think that's
adequate
training I think I'm ready to take
on the Berserker one more time all right
here we
go come on berserk man come at me
bro no no oh
[__]
okay am I playing Serious Sam here we
go all right r two I've already broken
my archery man's arm I'm going to go for
a long shot I missed
him
bam
okay ah got
it okay no get in get into the string
okay I can't even see where the dude is
where is he
okay this is this is man with
Shield got to wait for open that okay
here we go this is the one round four
get in this get in the knock okay I have
to nail this I have to nailed why are
they two of them and they've got Shields
oh well I'm [__]
dead H let's get one of them let's get
one of
them
a so close
all right what else we got going on here
we still got a we still got four game
modes and zombie
soccer war band uhoh oh great is this
just like Berserker mode but like dozens
of people
applean I think that's exactly what it
is oh what the
hell
okay
oh
right I really don't think all you
archery men should be taking my lead on
this but
sure check out how PR I'm at archering
archering ring re you put see what you
do everyone you put the arm out and then
you twist it yeah you got it yeah I know
they're getting close don't worry about
it I'm teaching you then you get the
thing and it's called knocking the arrow
you put it on the yeah exactly hold it
exactly like I'm doing it and then and
then you go you pull the string back you
let go of shift and then you go
wh yeah that's right we all aim at the
same guy so that we ensure our untimely
demise look at this nonsense all right
let's keep going just line up boys yep
all right who's ever whoever's played
this has clearly played Serius am all
right see the most annoying thing about
this is I know the minute I we we like
accurately kill all these guys it's just
going to come up wave two and there's
going to be like 50 more of them with
shields okay yeah just like last time
guys exactly
just the wrist yeah straighten it up and
then then you get in there and you knock
with the right click yeah and then you
pull it back and then you go
die a
[__] oh great we missed them all perfect
all right let's try it again with the
thing knock it knock knock it oh please
knock it please just knock knock all
right just throw your arrows at them
just throw your arrows at them
ah all right all
right wow the guys were still exploding
from the last round
do that straighten your elbows straight
elbows have I taught you
nothing give me my
arrow bend the thing yeah nailed it and
then you're going to here we
go all
right [__] okay higher slightly higher
this time okay a lot higher and also
maybe pull back on the string like I
didn't last time perfect [__] higher
again higher again knock the
arrow exact just wait till they're
really close that's it always works then
bam great keep going keep going keep
going yeah that's right keep
going [__] no closer there perfect oh oh
God damn it
a all right progress we're seeing
progress
imagine how maddening Skyrim would be if
they did
this those [__] mud crabs would be
murdering you every single
time bend the arm Bend the thing knock
the thing no don't point it towards
yourself you
idiots and pull it back and
release higher this
time great we got one of
them bam apples for dinner tonight
boys and again and then yeah and then do
it again nailed it oh great this guy got
through all right all right I think it
may be time for a break ladies and
gentlemen we'll be back in just a
minute's time after this awesome
commercial
break
I'll be honest I'm really looking
forward to playing zombie soccer all
right next egg Terminator egg puns we
always love those the more you break the
longer you take and the less you what oh
my God this is literally a dream come
true I've wanted to do this my entire
life okay I have to hit the egg without
hitting all the wonderful Croc
y okay I can do
this my pay is going down I was going to
get paid six grand wow
really yes look how Pro I am at this no
don't hit the cups and
stuff going to hit you egg oh [__] all
right it's okay we've got plenty more
plenty more kettles where that came
from I've only killed one of these
flying eggs and my boss told me to get
rid of all these terrifying flying eggs
out of the
store ah [__] all
right and maybe this guy no stop moving
stupid sentient flying
egg
God whoever made this game was clearly a
fan of psychedelics all
right no try that again
in this way knock the
arrow knock the
arrow yeah nailed it I hope he comes
hopefully he comes on my left side cuz
otherwise I'm not going to be able to
hit him
yes [__] try that again go back to the
left side
please h no wedged it in the
ceiling
go
up I find this background music
incredibly condescending okay ah
no does this guy have like double joints
all over
his all right come at
me my wages have been seed 6 and a half
Grand down to oh he near hit the
table oh
[__]
I got this Mr manager I'm sorry I've
only killed one of the Haunted egg
things please stop docking my
pay
uh he dodged that one that's
cheating
uh okay okay where you coming from where
you coming from I got it I got this like
like a turret thing going
on NOP another Kettle
gone
teapots can I shoot the lights
there I can't even shoot the
lights no no
there do I
am I stuck here forever is this
Purgatory I'm going to hit that
light no getting further away from
it if I'm going to get all my pay docked
I might as well enjoy myself while I do
it oh that was so
close
okay oh God I went straight through it
okay I've only got two grand worth of my
wages left
die look at him just taunting me just
flying directly past me look at this
look at this Pro archery look at that
the old broken arm
technique hold
on I hit the first one so
good it's like that was my one Zen
moment look at this he's breaking his
arms around
his bam
a come here flying egg I'm almost
bankrupt
a who's next Who's
Next
$1,200 left
come on no don't go underneath the table
is that's no
fair it's
cheating this game's got some hot
physics going on it's good thing we have
this physic card
installed no down that way yeah hit him
no 750 bucks left folks
I'm almost
bankrupt if I hit one more I'll be happy
I won't be happy that's a lie I've never
been happy but I'll be all
right yes I'm the
best no 420
yeah
a bastardy eggs come here one more I
feel like three isn't as
humiliating
yes ah I'm fired yeah well you're stupid
shitty stores haunted with flying eggs
so go eat
one next mode The Noose oh I think I can
guess what this
is why should I save these guys if
oh it's not it's one of my balloon face
men the rich lore of probably archery
really has a lot of emotional
hooks I feel like even if I manage to
save this
guy Jesus Christ even if I manage to
save it he's he's just going to get
murdered by those guys
anyway so why should I bother shouldn't
I just let him
die yeah it looks like it
whoops all
right I don't need to see the intro
every time video
game I get it life and death
situation knock the arrow knock the
arrow knock the
oh
okay oh for the love of God this is just
impossible do people actually are people
actually able to do this
one there
perfect
ah Robin Hood Doc Brown and Clint is so
managed
though when
did okay
okay
[__] oh well you're dead sorry
sorry we're getting closer I can feel
progress once
more here we go here we go here we
go nope nope he's dead sorry balloon
boy I'm starting to get Pro now cuz I'm
I'm using both my arms
I'm using both arms at the same time get
over there here we
go oh that was so
close okay okay oh no no no go back go
back go back I ain't done with you yet
noose oh
Jesus let's try that
again
oh you kidding me so close all
right just put him out of his misery
sorry dude sorry you're going to die
anyway I thought maybe I'd help you
out
okay no GNA have to turn you
more nailed
it okay
okay oh you son of a
bit all right
pivot no no oh
[__]
you always need that first shot to kind
of just judge
it
badly I'm going to get this I'm going to
get this and it is going to be
glorious
a
oh you kidding
me I could very easily spend an evening
attempting to do
this
happily
ah how many people have to die before I
manage to save one of
them although I'm convinced that they're
just going to die anyway
but no
no I don't I don't even know if this is
compelling viewing for you guys I'm
assuming not but I have goals in life
and they have to be
reached
oh the law of averages means at
least you know if we do this for at
least two hours I'll probably get one of
them
right yes
two hours I don't even need two hours
I'm the
best terrible Rope though yeah for sure
I'm backing
out
amazing life goal complete zero
g how I don't even
okay why is there a man running towards
me as well this is not fair how is he
this is deeply confusing to the
scientist inside of
me right all
right I will say it is a nice touch that
he is not screaming though because there
is no sound in space this guy would want
to get the hell out of the way though is
there another one can I just play with
his dead body for a while yeah I
can yeah look at that Apple zero g I'm
going to nail that dude
again
hey Apple
pece these these arrows are just going
to keep traveling like going to hit some
distant astronaut billions of miles away
just murder
him oh what I I made something
happen I made physics happen
ooh yeah
yeah c g archery is way
easier
bam I'm So Pro at as astronaut archery
astronaut
yes knock the arrow don't knock the
arrow
all
right all right I'm happy with zero
g and Target that's it that's amazing
all right you know what before we I
might dive into one of these again in a
second but I want to check out zombie
soccer CU this how do you not hit this
button over
here searching for a
match
ass
face I'm going have to host a game of
zombie soccer no one else will play with
me what the what's going on
sure I'm going to join
green all right what I got to do this is
a base cricket bat I'm already confused
as to what zombie soccer could be there
is no
goals oh Jesus Christ all right all
right I get it am I supposed to hit kill
the zombies with the
ball is that what this is die die
no no is there a goal oh there are goals
there are goals I'm an idiot
okay press and hold space to
kick oh yeah okay I got it I got it a
this is great I love when video games do
stupid soccer
modes there was one in a
it's kind of an American football
variant in Unreal Tournament 2004 I
think it
was here we go I'm going to bury this
goal I don't know what soccer team this
is that are all zombies though the only
one I can think of is that man united
team that all died in that plane crash
accident in the 70s maybe that's what it
is maybe this is a pissed off City fan
made this
game uh where'd it go get away I'm
playing soccer with my cricket bat
H
nope this reminds me of playing football
when I was in school where everyone runs
to the ball at the same time get away I
will score one
goal just tap it in Tipper taper the
problem with Arsenal is they try and
walk the ball into the
goal maybe they should play zombies get
in
I want to get let in if anyone's
watching this and wants to play by all
means join the [__]
server get out of the way these things
are you guys even going to kill me oh
yeah you're definitely going to murder
me
whoa
okay well that's a
problem do I get bullets if I score
goals or here we
go
Six Bullets
yeah I like how you get the
trails [__] uh okay where's the ball
G there it
is how did it even get over
here I'll be honest if there was a sport
called Zombie soccer I imagine there be
more people in the stadiums get
in yeah that's right hey boys
yeah
yeah kill me again I want a better
weapon or maybe I get the weapons for
scoring the
goal maybe that's what it is I don't
know I'm not from America I don't know
the rules of zombie
soccer bam going to chip everyone over
the
top that's right score from the tip off
bam
hatrick
all right I'm going to score from the
halfway line just like in FIFA
98 bam oh you prick how dare
you look at
that goie Defenders block got to kill
the murder the defender I got stuck on
the ball there here we go come
on no Go's come off his line get
shot no no
no like these Ice Hockey style
gos oh you guys are just the worst all
right come over
here
psych that is what we call a
nutmeg yay video
games all
right first the five wins okay I want to
see what happens at the
end boom straight in go
on off the
post he's
in
woohoo soccer zombie soccer that's what
it says and okay
sure can I do multiplayer and probably
archery is anyone playing
that Team
Deathmatch Co-op Team Deathmatch sounds
incredible nobody's playing
though
a mest unite dead nice work nerd City
Jim
all right I'm going to guess no one's
going to hop in
here I'm going to give that Berserker
mode one more
go I feel like I've gotten Pro enough in
all the other modes that this should be
not but a
dottle all right knock the
arrow knock the
arrow M no
no nailed
it
I'm going to hit him from
here
nope
bam I'm actually kind of surprised
nobody's playing this game online if I'm
honest you can go play like Alien versus
Predator and there are people still
playing that game that game came out 15
years ago you can t you can put Unreal
Tournament
on right now and people will still be
playing that game like original 1998
under tournament here we go bam all
right here we go this is it this is it
all your training has come down to this
owire
[__] a you stupid
Shields
boom God damn it probably archery all
right let's check out where you can buy
this video video game I believe it is
currently available on steam.com [__] no
I don't want Java what is this
1995 probably
archery probably archery available on
steam.com for the lowow price of
$9.99 once the page loads also I want to
show you guys this uh it's on indig Gala
I believe
come on
internet I know the internet is like
just falling under the weight of all
these probably archery streams that are
happening or game multiplayer games that
are
happening Steam down is Steam
down oh yeah I'll do it in the Steam app
good call bito thank you very
much no steam's being a real piece of
[__] right
now
bam a all right seems to being a [__]
but it is it is nine uh pound $9.99
which is probably I'm going to say
around $6.99 in uh Brit pounds in Queeny
pennies however if you go to indie.com
there is a a bundle running at the
moment and you can pick it up for four
bucks including a bunch of other games
including Supreme Commander which is you
know I know it's a bit old but that game
is pretty dope hostile Waters Humanity
asset probably archery that's if you go
in higher than four bucks otherwise for
one uh $1 you can get little race little
Racers Street Cami and uh and battle
paths so there you go so apparently I
think this this 12 this may be the first
12 hours already I'm not really sure
otherwise it's going to be$ 5.99 but to
be honest that's pretty good and then
you can have a whole collection of all
other new games that you're never going
to play again H that was random
encounter for today thank you very much
for joining me right here don't forget
we got a bunch of our live streams
coming up all week I wish I could tell
you what they are but I can't remember
off the top of my head what's on
tomorrow is it Peter
Brown Mega bit with Peter Bryan what's
he playing he's got that really crazy
it's
crazy some old game with an old
friend sure right here twitch.tv/
Gamespot uh otherwise uh multiple
players on Monday
Tuesday so is the
lobby it's early on a Wednesday I'm
pretty is it Wednesday today's Wednesday
or
Thursday Daniel on Twitter if you have
any suggestions for video games thanks
to all the dudes in production Dam hork
Bonito Gonzalez Eric Tay Max intern Max
the Hipster really appreciate you guys
uh hanging out and play properly archery
go play our video game it's good fun uh
I will see you guys next week adios
totally
missed